all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics uh first of all please mute
yourself during the talk but uh if you
have question you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
in Q&A session second today's gdps
seminar is open to external audience so
no classified discussion is allowed
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded it in our YouTube channel
that's about it now let me uh briefly
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host uh the Dimitrius um who is
a the Jack burn the professor in
mathematics at dartm Marth College he
received bachelor's and master's degree
in Natural Sciences from the University
of Cambridge in 2001 and PhD degree in
physics from the University of Chicago
in 2009
following a post-doctoral appointment um
at the Kuran Institute of mathematical
science in New York uh University from
209 to 2012 he was an assistant
professor and associate professor of of
mathematics at kurant until
20121 when he joined the Department of
Mathematics at
Dartmouth his current research focus is
at the interface between operator
theoretic techniques for dynamical
systems and and machine learning and his
recent uh work includes the development
of techniques for coherent pattern uh
pattern extractions statistical
forecasting and data assimilation based
on the datadriven approximations of cman
operators of dynamical systems he has
worked on the applications of these
tools to Atmosphere ocean science uh
fluid dynamics and molecular Dynamics
today um the Demetrius uh is going to
talk about the quantum information and
data science for modeling classical
Dynamics um please expect a wonderful
talk and the stage is yours now
dimetrius thank you Yu Yu for inviting
me thank you everyone for coming uh in
person or uh remotely so we'll be
talking about uh techniques from Quantum
information science and uh kopman
operator theory for for modeling uh
classical dynamical systems uh this is
in work done in collaboration with
several people that I will acknowledge
as we go through uh through the Tog so
so so to if it this will allow okay so
to begin I I I usually like to show this
snippet from um classical paper of uh of
Hineman which in some ways ushered in
the era of quantum Computing where um
the idea that uh he puts forward is that
if nature is fundamentally quantum
mechanical we should be using Quantum
systems to simulate uh to simulate
nature in other words Quantum systems
should be used to simulate other uh uh
Quantum systems um um forming some
notion of universal Quantum computation
so now the problem I would like to talk
about today is um kind of in the uh
Converse uh Direction namely um we would
like to use quantum systems to simulate
classical systems um and uh the idea
being that uh uh we want to harness the
power uh that uh you know Quantum
systems have that are not present in
terms of information processing that are
not that do not have classical analogues
um to obtain some type of computational
Advantage so this is a a problem that
has also um uh received uh a lot of
attention in in recent years uh this is
just a partial um list of of references
uh where uh people have looked at
different kinds of classical systems and
designed Quantum um algorithms or
thought about uh ways of incorporating
um quantum mechanical descriptions to to
simulate them uh so one U of the
challenges here is that uh there's a
little bit of a disparity between the
fact that uh you know classical
dynamical systems are usually formulated
in terms of nonlinear systems of you
know differential equations either
ordinary differential equations or or
partial uh differential equations
whereas um Quantum systems if you
exclude at least measurement they they
evolve with um unitary linear linear
operations so there is a you know um uh
immediate challenge about how to encode
a nonlinear Dynamics in terms of unitary
or linear evolution um and there are
also other complexities involved having
to do with how you prepare the state of
the quantum computer to encode given
initial conditions um of the classical
system and also at the end of the
computation how to how to appropriately
measure um the quantum state to extract
the the the you know the information
that we want to predict the quantity of
interest to the to for in the simulation
um so these are all um challenging and
um interesting questions and I will be
talking about work we've been doing um
uh with uh collaborators in you know
hoping to address at least part of them
sorry but okay okay so um I should say
also that um I'm happy to be interrupted
um and anytime during the talk with
questions even if I don't get through
the entire material so we will be using
um our methodology relies heavily on the
operator theoretic uh approaches to um
dynamical systems which um uh have been
developed in work of uh V noyman kopman
and others dating back to the 19 uh
1930s and in this in this framework one
um focuses on the um induced action of
generally nonlinear Dynamics on Spaces
of observables so uh meaning functions
of the state these are quantities that
uh one can measure like a temperature or
velocity in fluid flow um and the idea
here is that these spaces you know
spaces of functions um if the um the the
codomain so the output space is is a
linear space like a vector space often
times this will be the real or or
complex numbers these spaces are are
actually linear meaning we can add
together functions we can scale or
multiply functions even if the
underlying State space of the classical
system is uh does not have a linear
structure and remarkably um uh if we
have a u generally nonlinear flow um I'm
denoting it here by ft on on a classical
stat space and by that I mean that there
is a this family of mappings
parameterized by time such that they
take in initial conditions on the state
Space X and output the state that the
system has reached after dynamical
Evolution for time T and this is
generally yes excuse me I'm sorry I'm
Henry uh I so before you go further can
you maybe like give a few like example
of
like in a physical system what is X what
is VT yeah thanks for the for the
question so uh maybe to have as a mental
model uh a concrete example suppose that
X is uh uh you know three-dimensional
space or some ukian space RN and uh we
have on X we have specified a system of
n ordinary differential equations uh
think of for instance the LA
63 uh you know system that has the you
know chaotic butterfly attractor or
think of the simple harmonic oscillator
if you know X was uh R2 where you have
you know position and momentum uh
represented in that space so you write
down a system of equations you know DX
by DT equals um uh V of X where V is
some Vector field and you solve the the
initial value problem that comes out um
of that and the solution defines this
this dynamical uh this dynamical flow VT
this is the the map that basically is
the solution map for a system of uh
differential
equations uh and you know these can also
be generalized to systems of partial
differential equations where now X
instead of being uh finite dimensional
space like uh RN it's actually itself a
function space if you if you're dealing
with a fluid mechanical model so X would
be a space of functions on some domain
where you know the fluid flow takes
place um does that uh help clarify it
yeah yeah thanks thanks yeah and and
again please interrupt me if anything is
not clear so so now given that we have
such
a a flow we can define linear operators
uh associated with that flow that um
they act by uh composition so a natural
such
operator which is now known the cman
operator takes observable so functions
in this space um are suitably chosen and
composes them from the right with with a
dynamical flow uh so this effectively
defines a transformation that takes
functions and produces new functions you
can think of the function f uh composed
with ft as some type of time evolved
version of of f where instead of
evaluating um f at the at any given
classical State we're evaluating it at
since we're composing with this map
we're evaluating at the state that the
system has reached after evolution by
time T and you can check that this
transformation is actually linear um
that the way we Define this map from
functions to functions is actually a
linear map this is now known as the cman
operator um a related operator that is
Al also quite useful um is the transfer
operator also known as Peron robinus
operator um and this is actually like an
adjoint you can think of it as an
adjoint of the cman operator which um is
defined on the Dual on a dual space to f
um I I I don't want to go uh into the
technical details here but we're
thinking that uh for instance um uh uh
if F was a space of continuous functions
on X then the Dual space would be some
space of of measures like like for
instance probability probability
measures and um the Peron robinus
operator describes the um the action of
a dynamical system on Spaces of of
measures um and this is useful in uh
studying probabilistic aspects of uh uh
classical Dynamics namely how
probability distributions evolve under
uh general you know nonlinear Dynamics
um this has applications in forecasting
uncertainty quantification um and so on
but the main message here is that this
this perspective allows one basically to
study uh general you know nonlinear
Dynamics uh by leveraging tools from the
theory of linear operators um this is um
this is something that has received this
approach has received uh a fair amount
of attention in um
uh in the in recent in recent years
because these linear operator theoretic
techniques um are also well suited for
datadriven implementation uh it turns
out or datadriven approximation where we
use we use um uh observations of the
system collected along dynamical
trajectories uh to build um
approximations of the cman or transfer
operator and use them for different
different purposes uh the primary
applications being spectral
decomposition of data it turns out that
these operators when you know formulated
in an appropriately CH on appropriately
chosen spaces they have useful um
spectral properties so the their for
instance their igen functions
characterize uh they can characterize
periodic or approximately periodic uh uh
observables uh under uh under the flow
um and and this can be used for um so P
pattern extraction or feature extraction
from dynamically generated data um and
the other application is uh prediction
or or
modeling and an uncertainty
quantification now for for the purposes
of you know this talk here um uh what I
will be focusing rather are on the
connections between this approach this
this General framework uh of kman kman
and transfer operators with a quantum
theory so mathematically um it turns out
that there are some deep deep uh
correspondences and relationships
between uh between the two fields which
I hope I will I will highlight and uh
and also kind of like motivate this this
framework as an as a way to build a
bridge to um effectively encode
classical Dynamics in terms of quantum
Quantum systems so this is like a
natural language in some sense uh to do
that okay so uh this um uh maybe here
maybe for this audience this is not
strictly necessary but I I have like a
one slide summary of the basic axioms of
quantum quantum mechanics um which we
will be using later on um and uh in in
many ways you can think of a Quantum uh
this Quantum um set of quantum
mechanical actions as being analogous to
um uh classical statistics where you
replace objects like probability
densities which are functions and
observables which are again functions by
operators so it's some type of you can
think of it operator theoretic or
non-commutative version of classical
classical probability um and the the um
uh one of the fundamental uh Notions
that we have is that of a density
operator so basically a Quantum State
we're going to describe it by an
operator that acts on on a hilber space
um and that choice of h kber space will
depend on the system at hand for
something like the hydrogen atom it
would be like a space of functions over
threedimensional
space um for a spin uh system could be
like a fin dimensional hilber space this
will depend on the system that we have
at hand uh but uh but a density operator
is an operator that has uh that is
positive um uh meaning it a joint and
its Spectrum lies in the positive uh
real line uh it's um it has it is of
Trace class so it has finite trace and
it's normalized in the sense that its
Trace is equal to one you can think of
it as somehow being analogous to um a
probability density function that one
has In classical statistics in the sense
that a probability density function is a
positive function um it is
integrable and its integral is equal to
one so thinking here of Trace has been
somewhat analogous to integration uh
makes that
correspondence um now uh observables in
quantum mechanics are again operators in
fact they are self adjoined operators
acting on the Hilbert space here for
Simplicity I'm going to think in terms
of bounded observables that doesn't
necessarily have to be the case but um
we don't have to worry about that now um
and um and the self adjointness here you
can think of it as being analogous to
having real valued functions classical
observables so self adjoint operators
have real Spectra which um is analogous
to having uh real uh to to being real
viid functions now the um uh quantum
theory gives us a um a recipe or like
for set of rules for comp uting
expectations of measurements of
observables given that the system is in
a certain Quantum State and evaluating
their their probability uh outcomes um
and again this
generalized familiar Notions from
classical statistics so if we have a
system that is in Quantum State row is
has an Associated density operator row
and we have a bounded classical uh
bounded Quantum observable we can
compute this Trace um uh and and that
gives us a number which is we interpret
as the expected uh value of measurements
of a when the system is in Quantum State
row um and again thinking of uh Trace as
being analogous to integration row as
being analogous to to a probability
density and a as being analogous to a
you know classical you know um uh
observable the this formula here should
look somewhat familiar from somewhat
analogous to expectation of you know
classical um In classical statistics now
quantum theory also gives us a a a
recipe for computing the probability of
outcomes of measurement so if I have if
we have a set Omega that uh that um uh
is like some set of Interest let's say
an interval and we want to compute the
probability that a measurement of a
weelye on that inter interval we can
compute that again um by as a Quantum
EXP expectation of a new Quantum
observable um U which is basically the
uh spectral measure associated with a I
don't want to go now in the um in more
details here but think of this as uh
being somewhat analogous to uh when when
you want to compute the probability of
an event in classical statistics you can
write the probability of an event as an
expectation value of a characteristic
function that you know basically indexes
represents that uh event uh here this
spectral measure is some Quantum version
you can of a of a characteristic
function it's a it's a projection
operator um that uh we can use to
compute probabilities of um measurement
now the um evolution of a Quantum State
takes place uh under unitary um uh
Dynamics between when when we are not
measuring the system so we assume that
there is a unitary operat Ator U UT that
acts on um density Maps Pro Quantum
density operators to Quantum density
operators by means of this conjugation
uh identity um in quantum physics this
is known as the shringer picture of
quantum Quantum Evolution um and it's
linear that's meaning these operators
here are
linear um and um and the last piece that
I want to uh to bring up here is that
just as in classical statistics we can
condition probability densities um by um
uh when we have observed events using
you know base rule there is an analogous
uh conditioning um um uh uh uh procedure
for conditioning Quantum states by
so-called Quantum events so what are
quantum events so Quantum events are
again operators everything is an
operator here um which have the property
of being positive and lying between the
zero operator and the identity uh uh
operator these are also known as Quantum
effects and uh again you can think of
this uh in in in a sort of classical
analogy with the fact that when you have
an event that you're conditioning a
probability density that event you can
represent by a characteristic function
and a characteristic function is a
function that takes values between the
zero function and the function that is
uh uh equal to one um uh everywhere and
and this this generalizes that um now
this formula here uh you you you will
see that you know we have this square
root that appears on both sides of the
uh density uh operator um which looks
somewhat different from the classical
version uh of Bas Bas rule when you
write it down well the reason is that in
we're dealing with these non-commutative
spaces of operators um if we were able
to commute multiplication of the square
root of e with row we could write this
as row time e which would then look
closer to what um you know um a
conditioning in the classical world
would look like uh but um because uh
we're not in general allowed to do this
this is the formula that we are we're
going to be using okay so we have now
this uh set of aums maybe I should pause
quickly to ask if there are any any
questions
uh so what we want to do sorry I do have
a question I'm sorry so like uh can you
I'm a little unfamiliar with like coming
coming from a physics background I'm
familiar with like 0.1 to 4 can you say
a little more about the fifth Point
State conditioning by measurement like
what is it what are you measuring uh
it's uh so um so the
uh here um I'm thinking of uh uh
for for every measurement there's a one
can assign uh by measurement here I mean
these Quantum events or or effects uh uh
so if you want to think of it purely as
a without you know focusing so much on
the the choice of words here and then I
can try to clarify that uh think of that
whenever you have an operator e that has
this property it has this it's called a
Quantum uh a Quantum uh uh effect then
uh then there is this this this formula
that is um basically giving you a a
Quantum version of of Base Rule now when
when you're actually making um a
measurement and um if we want to think
at least of the measurement as a as a
type of a of a yes or no um answer yes
or no question uh it turns out that you
can write down a um um an effect uh you
can write down an e for depending on
that depends on the whether you got the
answer yes or the answer no and you can
condition the state by this um by this
effect this is basically analogous to
what one might call the wave function
quotes collapse I don't know if I want
to really use that that word but this is
basically um uh somewhat
analogous analogous to that I mean for
for us we're going to think of it more
uh in in a uh statistical sense or we're
going to use it in a mathematical way
sense to to to um update Quantum states
by um uh outcomes of uh of of
observations of our system hopefully
this will become a little bit clearer
later on but so I mean can you say like
this is what happens after you make a
measurement
uh in um yes you you can you can say
that yeah yeah uh but but also sorry I
will but also you can use that formula
not just in the context of a physical
Quantum measurement like in terms of
like a a hardware uh uh based
measurement but you can also think of it
as an inference formula similarly to how
you would treat you know basian you know
base rule for inference so what terms
this kind of projection yeah sub
Subspace
um this this map here projections will
have that property there will be uh
Quantum effects but not every Quantum
effect is necessarily a projection but
yeah that's a good point like
projections are going to be a part of
this
okay uh all right so now um I want to go
over like um uh like a big picture
picture overview of how we use these
these axioms to uh represent uh a
classical dynamical system by a Quantum
uh Quantum system so as as we mentioned
earlier uh we're starting from from uh a
classical dynamical flow on a on a state
space uh and we want to embed this
classical flow eventually to a Quantum
system and we're going to do this by
passing through um a few intermediate
levels uh the first one of which will be
to embed classical EV evolution of
classical States into evolution of
classical probability U distributions
the way to do that so here P of X
denotes a space of probability measures
over X um so um with you know reasonable
assumptions this this is like a nice
space in a mathematical uh mathematical
sense and uh the um the map that that
allows us to do that is basic it's it's
very natural it takes points in X and
map them to their corresponding direct
Delta measures at that point so
essentially what we're we're doing here
we're creating a copy of our system into
um into this page of probability
measures that we can always do I mean
there are more of course probability
measures in here that just the direct
measures but we get an injective mapping
like a onet to one mapping into um into
the space p of X and on this space p of
X we can use this Peron frous operator
that I I introduced earlier on uh which
is this it's a composition map by um uh
the inverse flow it turns out um uh to
to um evolve probability measures over
time and the important thing about this
type of embedding is that it's
dynamically consistent in the sense that
this diagram here commutes by that I
mean that if you start from a a given
classical initial condition you embed it
into a a probability measure uh uh
sending it to its corresponding dra
evolving it under the transfer operator
you get to the same point as first
evolving your classical condition and
then embedding it uh with the same
formula so it's dynamically consistent
in that manner now what we want to do
next is starting from this this um this
uh level of description so to speak we
want to um now create another uh
embedding which uh takes classical
probability measures into Quantum States
so here H is a a a hilber space that we
will have to choose we'll have to think
about how to define it and Q of H
denotes the space of quantum States on
that hilber space so for us this will be
the set of you know Trace class positive
operators of unit of unit trays um and
um we uh we want to define a a mapping
uh that do will be an embedding that uh
uh according here gamma that takes
probability classical probability
measures and creates uh you know from
them Quantum you know Quantum States and
we we also want to prescribe an
evolution map U that acts on this uh on
this Quantum States uh this would be
some kind of like lifted version of the
Peron forus operator that makes this
diagram commute so in in effect um this
will give us um this will give us a copy
of our system into an quantum mechanical
quantum mechanical uh system now this
system is going to be typically infinite
dimensional um in order to have of
course practical algorithms uh we want
to project into finite dimensions and um
and in particular we want to to to to um
if if the goal is to create um Quantum
computational algorithms we want to pro
project our system uh into a Quantum
system that is defined on a hilber space
which is associated with a certain
number of cubits so it has B suban here
I'm denoting as a tensor product Hilbert
space associated with n n cubits the
goal is we want to define a um project
choose our projection map in a suitable
way such that um we can have a uh
Evolution acting at the level of cubits
that is in some sense um uh on the one
hand efficient that allows which means
that we can implement it with a you know
um modest number of uh comput
uh Lo Quantum logic gates um and also
it's consistent in the sense that this
diagram here should commute or at least
commute asymptotically as the number of
cubits um increases um and and that that
is uh that is uh kind of the the end
goal now the the key points that um I
want no probably I will not get to the
the very end of everything that I wanted
to say but so let me say what what are
the key points here um uh there are two
points that I want to highlight the
first is that even if we Implement these
methods classically like after all you
know these are basically um one could in
principle simulate this system
classically at the level of operators is
basically dealing with linear algebra
when you're working in finite dimensions
um uh uh what I'd like to to to one of
the messages I'd like to to to get
across is that even um if implemented
classically working with this uh Quantum
formalisms has certain desirable or
useful numerical numerical properties
certain aspects of um uh structure
preservation that are very natural
almost automatic when you're working
with operators or like matrices in
finite Dimensions um as opposed to
functions I will focus here on
positivity preservation um and the other
the other uh aspect um is that for some
classes of systems I mean which is by no
mean an exhaustive class I will I will
specify that later on we do have a um a
way to um to design circuits that
implement this evolution in a man in a
manner that um is efficient or it has
some type of advant advantage and I will
I will try to be specific about what
what is that uh uh Advantage later on
but these are the main the main two
points so I'm going to highlight um uh
give like U some uh examples from uh our
work first we're dealing more with this
um this uh part where we uh design uh
algorithms which are quantum inspired
but they're implemented classically
um and uh uh and then on the second part
talk about talk about implementations on
Quantum circuit so this is this is this
first part is in work in collaboration
with David kman and Brian mids who are
PhD students from Dartmouth Joanna
slawinska who is also from Dartmouth and
abas uras from University of Wisconsin
um mili and I will be talking about uh
ideas from from um using Quantum
information
science or quantum theory to perform
data data simulations of classical
dynamical systems so what is the goal
here in data data simulation well the
goal is that you have the objective
rather is that we have a dynamical
system that we observe only
partially um and in a classical
dynamical system and we have classical
observations and we want to infer the
state of that system uh under sequential
measurement so so the idea is that we
could start from a highly uncertain
knowledge of the state um and even
though we're observing the system
partially uh over time we can refine our
knowledge and get a good estimate of the
underlying state so this is an integral
piece of many sort of like numerical um
modeling systems like weather uh
prediction or object tracking and it it
has many applications um in practice so
so the the the the approach that we're
going to use is um basically along the
lines of what I've been describing
already um what uh I'm going to be here
a little bit more specific and how how
we actually Define our hilber spaces and
our um you know spaces of classical
observables which I hadn't talked about
previously first um you know if we're
going to uh embed into a Quantum system
we have to choose a hilber space so in
the context of data simulation a natural
choice of a space is uh if you have a
dynamical system that is measure
preserving so this this is going to be
um an assumption we're going to assume
that there is a um invariant probability
distribution of the system think of it
that there is some kind of uh
statistical equilibrium the system
itself like the probabilities that we're
going to be looking at they do not have
to be in in equilibrium but um we're
thinking that there is some underlying
equilibrium distribution and the
probability measures that we're looking
at they have densities with respect to
that um equilibrium distribution so this
is the typical setup one has in uh in in
in in classical data assimilation and um
now uh as our our space of observables
we're going to um um look at bounded
functions with respect to to to that to
that uh uh probability measure now um we
can think of this space this this space
of observables as um is actually an
algebra of observables what do I mean by
that it has the property of uh not just
being a vector space like a linear space
where you have addition and scalar
multiplication but it's also it has an
extra operation namely you can multiply
together two two uh functions in the
space and they stay in in in that space
and the operation is continuous in a
suitable sense with respect to the norm
of the space so we have an um an algebra
and and it is a commutative algebra
because it it doesn't matter in which
order you multiply you know functions um
later on we're going to embed this in a
in a
non-commutative uh algebra of operators
so in fact um this is what we're going
to do now this is how um how um how we
um uh embed our our uh classical
probability densities into um into
Quantum state so it's the uh it's
basically a formula that takes a
probability measure that has a density
with respect to um with respect to um
the invariant measure mu uh and call
that density I'm calling it new this is
a function which is integrable because
it's a probability density so it is
positive so we can take its square root
and its square root is going to be
square integrable so it will live in our
hilber space and if we Define that um
that um um uh uh operator which is a
projection operator that projects along
the square root of the probability
density that defines for as a Quantum um
a Quantum State this is a density
operator so this procedure is is uh
known um as the kman vman embedding uh
Elon and others have done a lot of of
work uh on on this on this topic or even
more General uh versions of this where
you allow also um the D here to have a
complex a complex phase uh this is this
here we're looking at real valued um uh
densities um and so we have this uh
embedding and and the nice thing about
it is that it makes this diagram commute
where the commutation here the the
evolution of quantum State takes by
means of the of the the cman operator
acting on on probability on uh density
operators by this conjugation formula we
had talked uh
about earlier now um so we we've talked
about how to embed classical States now
we can also embed classical observables
um after all we we want to have both
representation of states and observables
as a Quantum um system and the way we
can do that is basically by mapping
functions to bounded operators on our
Hilbert space so this will be Quantum
observables um which uh are
multiplication operators that multiply
by those functions so here Pi is a map
that takes a function to an operator so
Pi of f is an operator and and Pi of f
is defined as the operator that
multiplies by F so in quantum mechanics
there are um in quantum physics you know
multiplication operators there are many
examples of them one one of them being
let's say the position operator in a
one-dimensional um onedimensional system
here we're defining them for General
observables in this space L Infinity it
is important that we're looking at
bounded observables because um to make
this operator bounded this
multiplication operator and the uh
consistency relation that we get uh at
the end so this is um why this you know
di diagram commute and this is why
effectively we're creating a copy of our
system in into a Quantum system is that
we can compute uh we can use the
transfer operator to evolve classical
probability densities and compute
expectations classical expectations
without time evolved with respect to the
time Evol density or we can embed
Quantum mechanically use the the quantum
mechanical version of the transfer
operator and compute a Quantum
expectation of the corresponding
multiplication operator Pi of f so
basically it's this formula over here
and we get the same result as the
classical expectation in other words we
have created a um um uh a copy for all
intents and purposes of our system into
this infinite dimensional uh Quantum uh
Quantum system now we want this uh of
course at the end of the day we want to
do numerical computation so the next
step will be actually to as I mentioned
earlier as well will be to project the
system onto finite Dimensions now here
I'm not focusing on doing Quantum
computing so it's not important that the
the hilber space the finite dimensional
hilber space is um has the tensor
product structure associated with with
cubits here we're imagining a more
General situation where we have some
finite dimensional hilber space which is
a Subspace of H of our infinite
dimensional uh hilber space and we
orthogonally project everything onto
that onto that Subspace um now we can we
can uh project States um assuming that
this denominator here doesn't doesn't
vanish so for every state for which this
denominator doesn't vanish we can
project down um a state from the
infinite dimensional setting to a finite
dimensional uh State and we can also um
create um an evolution of of uh of
states by means of this um this formula
here which where we basically using a
projected projected you know Quantum
projected cman uh operator for for that
for that part now in general um if we do
that this diagram here does not commute
that's why I put here this dotted arrows
unless you know in some special cases
for instance if if H Abel was a finite
Union of cman igen spaces then you know
for particular choices of H sub L this
diagram will commute exactly but we
don't want to restrict ourselves in that
situation
however if we have L as being some
parameter that controls the dimension of
our approximation and as L increases
these spaces increase towards H this
diagram here will commute in asymptotic
asymptotic sense so this um this is the
level that we operate uh numerically We
have basically our Quantum states are
density matrices now they're finite rank
finite rank operators and numerical
linear algebra with you know Matrix
algebra um and this is now one one of
these highlights that I was I wanted to
make earlier is that um this this uh
numerical setup allows us to um easily
preserve some structures of the problem
that uh would in ways that would not be
possible by um um if we were working in
spaces of functions and what do I mean
by that well um if you take a a
classical probability density like a
function which is a function which is
positive if you do an orthogonal
projection of a positive function let's
say you were representing in a numerical
scheme um a a classical density as a uh
in a basis like in a FIA basis or some
type of um uh discretization basis that
one chooses if you're using a orthogonal
projection to to to arrive at your
approxim
um that approximation need not be
positive um and you know there are
things behaviors like the Gibbs
phenomenon for instance when you take
you know a toput function and you
project it into finitely many FIA
functions which do not do not um
preserve positivity um at least not
through orthogonal projections you have
to do something more less trivial in
order to preserve positivity on the
other hand preserving positivity of
operators is is much comparatively much
easier um if you take an operator and
you conjugate it from the left and right
by a positive operator and you
conjugated by projections the result is
um is a positive operator so the the the
the the mthod here is that um uh by by
passing first by embedding first our
system into this infinite dimensional
Quantum system and using that as our
starting point to build numerical uh
approximations uh puts us in a in a um
in a space where we we have uh the
ability to um preserve uh certain uh
aspects of the original system like
positivity of States but also it turns
out positivity of observables um in ways
that uh are either that're not possible
in spaces of functions using equivalent
operations like orthogonal analogous
operations like orthogonal projections
so I would I would Advocate that this um
is a reason to to at least think about
this type of methodologies even if the
if they're not implemented in quantum
computers even if they're used in you
know classical
numerics okay so in the um in data
simulation uh as I as I mentioned
earlier we imagine that we have a um a
classical system that is evolving over
time we are we don't have knowledge of
its state but we observe its state every
you know certain number of time steps if
we're doing some kind of um uh dis you
know discreet in time um uh uh
approximation um and uh we're going to
represent our knowledge of our of of
that system by uh by a Quantum state so
in data simulation classical data
simulation this knowledge would be
represented by a probability density
here we're going to use a density Matrix
like um like we had uh before and uh the
idea is that we alternate between uh
forecast and measurement this is the the
typical cycle one has in data
assimilation between observations we use
the transer operator acting on on on the
density matrices to evolve to evolve um
our our density to um a new density and
then when the uh when we measure make a
measurement of the system and
measurement here I mean purely in the
classical sense we have a a sensor like
a or like a network of sensors that
they're giving us observations so we're
measuring a function of the state of our
classical system there's a we use the
the quantum version of of Base rule that
I showed earlier to update the state and
for that we have to use basically a a
map uh like I was talking about earlier
we have to assign to every observation
and a corresponding Quantum effect uh so
like a a Quantum event if you want to
think of it like that way um we we we do
that in practice using uh uh kernel
methods um like feature Maps uh from um
uh reproducing Kel H spaces with a
difference that being in the quantum uh
in the quantum world we have to use um a
matrix valid or operator valid feature
Maps I'm happy to talk about some of
this of line uh later on um so and and
you know and the scheme we it's
basically numerically we can U implement
it using data that we collect along U
dynamical trajectories uh in a training
phase so it's basically like a data
driven data simulation scheme um so I I
guess I talk through that so in the
interest of time I will not spend too
much time here but just to just I want
to uh emphasize that um we can compute
predictions or forecasts of classical
observables using Quantum expectations
but we can also uh implic we're
basically carrying U um we're
representing entire forecast
distributions because with our Quantum
State and the spectral resolution of our
observables we can compute probabilities
for measurements to take values um in in
different sets of Interest let's say you
want to predict that the temperature um
at a given location you know two days
from today will will lie in a certain
interval this can be encoded in this um
in this uh uh
manner okay I'm going to show one um
example uh uh where we did that in the
context of climate climate Dynamic so uh
this is a uh using uh data that as
training that was generated from a
climate model So currently we're working
also on I'm doing this from actual
observational data but um the idea is
that we're making observations of the in
of indopacific sea surface temperature
Fields so we're observing um the
temperature of the surface temperature
of the ocean in in a domain that is
roughly like shown here and from that we
want to make um a prediction about the
elino phenomenon so the elenos sou
oscillation is um an oscillatory process
that manifested itself with um anomalous
anomalously warm or anomalously cold
Waters um in the tropical Pacific Ocean
um to the west of um South South America
so Al Nino events are anomalously warm
and the corresponding Lanas are
anomalously cold this is an oscillation
that takes place with a characteristic
time scale of um know 3 to seven years
um approximately uh currently we are in
an Lino here and um the way um climate
scientists index or monitor this uh this
phenomenon is by means of conventionally
at least by means of uh So-Cal Nino
indices so the these are basically um uh
area average sea surface temperature
Fields over given domains in the
tropical uh Pacific Ocean we're going to
use this Nino 3.4 index which is the
average SST in this box over here here
which is uh probably the most one of the
more common uh indices for uh for Eno so
um we took this um this data and we you
know we run it through um the pipeline
that uh I just mentioned and um uh this
is basically just an uh an output uh of
of what this method produces these are
basically uh running forecasts of the El
Nino Nino 3.4 index in a uh uh I think
uh 50 or so or sorry 20 years of um an
un arbitrary interval um of a test data
set that we had isolated from from this
model um and in in the in the red line
we're showing the the true um evolution
of the uh Nino 3.4 index the black line
is showing the evolution that uh the the
quantum we get from the quantum
expectation um from this from this uh
numerical numerical scheme here in the
horizontal axis we have the the forecast
verification time so it's like the day
for which we are making the forecast and
as we go down the panel we we are
increasing the lead time is how many
days in advance we are predicting and
the behavior here that that and that you
can see well I should also say that the
colors here correspond to the
probability or logarithms of the
probability density um that again is
encoded in our Quantum State uh computed
through the spectral measure of our
observable that we're using to also
characterize
uncertainty of forecasting and you can
see as we go down the panels um uh as
you know one might expect forecast
uncertainty increases uh as well as you
know the the the error for the forecast
but is doing a pretty decent job uh at
least for this type of U you know
modeled uh modeled data
okay so um I think I'm almost running
out of time uh so I will U uh skip you
know basically a lot of what I I had in
mind I will say maybe just a few words
uh about the actual Quantum uh Quantum
uh implementation if I can take a three2
yeah
yeah yeah um so so so in this part uh
and I'm just going to give a quick
summary of this
uh uh we are now interested in in
besides you know this numerical you know
classical numerical uh procedure that I
you know outlined for data simulation
now we're interested in actually
implementing this uh you know the
versions of this uh algorithms onto
Quantum quantum computers this is work
done with uh people listed uh listed
here and and the um the the the focus
here is is that rather than having our
finite dimensional approximation be
space be a general you know finite
dimensional hilber space we want to
explicitly focus in the case where the
hilber space that we are projecting has
the structure of an enfold tensor
product of two dimensional kilber spaces
associated with n n cubits of a quantum
computer so this this space here will
have Dimension 2 to the power n um and
um there is a there is basically um a
canonical basis that one can choose for
for one can use for for this tensor
product hilber space that you can
represent by binary strings index by
binary strings of length U length uh uh
n and and the basis vectors are tensor
products of these basic vectors that are
um we labeled them this dra cat notation
either zero um and and one um so we have
this uh this
setup here um and you know this space
here has Dimension 2 to the power n uh
so an exponentially large Dimension we
want to create here the goal is to
create an evolution Pro uh create find a
projection map such that it Maps our
transfer operator into a finite
dimensional finite rank operator that
can be implemented efficiently using a
um uh ideally using a polinomial number
of uh Quantum Gates um uh in this
exponentially large dimensional hilber
space um so this is something that we're
actively working on so far you know um
and we've had a lot of discussions with
Elon and others on that as well uh so so
so far we we have um looked at this
particular case of so-called systems
that have pure Point Spectrum so these
are canonically we can represent them as
iic rotations on on torai um so this is
a Formula that I'm showing here for the
dynamical evolution this will be our
canonical working example but um uh in
fact this this is representative of a
wider class of system so we can bring
other systems U that have this pure
Point Spectrum Property into this
canonical form of anodic to Rotation by
um continuous um continuous uh uh
Transformations that are compatible with
the Dynamics these are known top as
topological uh conjugacies so this will
be our canonical um example that we're
going to we're going to study um uh I'm
going to skip here through uh a few
things but the the idea is that we want
to choose a hilber space that is adapted
to this uh to this kind of this uh this
uh type of systems and uh and we're not
going to be using an L2 space in this
application we're going to use a
different class of hilber space known as
uh reproducing kernel hilber space is
defined um by means of a kernel that we
we we we have on our on our taus um and
the key property that this space has in
addition to being a reproducing kernel
hilber space that it's also again a um
an algebra with respect to pointwise
multiplication of functions this is a
non-trivial property to have for a
reproducing kernel hilber space um but
but but for this specific choice of
Kernel that we're using we have it and
the reason is that we want to have this
properties because we want to represent
classical observables of functions in
that hilber space by bounded
multiplication uh multiplication
operators and the this type of um uh the
these class of spaces have been St
extensively in in harmonic analysis um
in uh by fating or collaborators and um
among you know there's a there's a large
literature and we've made some
contributions in that as well um uh I'm
going to you know Skip a bunch of stuff
uh the the the the the point being that
with this particular choice of spaces
we're going reproducing kernel Hilbert
algebras were're able to R retain a lot
of structures that is uh uh you can find
in in different spaces but here we're
putting them all in one um
uh setup and this is useful for for uh
designing our Quantum algorithms okay so
the main point is that you know once we
go through this um Machinery is that if
we take a a a system that has pure Point
spectrum and we look at its we can find
basically a projection map that takes
our uh kopman operator or more precisely
the generator of the cman group to a
hamiltoni so we're defining we're using
a hamiltonian to define a Quantum system
that is um very nicely factorizable in
um in terms of um as a sum of commuting
operators which are very simple in the
sense that each oper each of these
operators that appears in the sum is a
tensor product of identity operators
with only one po Z operator that acts on
an individual Cubit so effectively what
we're doing we're representing the this
ergodic system that has pure Point
Spectrum as a a bunch of phase rotations
that are acting on individual cubits
this is very uh um special in the uh
because it won't work for any dynamical
system I want to stress that um it's
actually non-trivial to to generalize it
but but for this kind of systems um we
do have an efficient uh representation
of our Quantum hamiltonian that allows
us to exponentiate and get a very nice
um very simple um almost trivially
simple Quantum circuit uh this is how
the pipeline work as I mentioned earlier
you know in addition to the to the
evolution which um we we do efficiently
by our um the circuit that I just
highlighted or the the uh highlighted
there are these problems of how do you
encode the initial condition and how do
you make a measurement at the end where
U uh gives you which which gives you a
consistent uh information about the
observable that you want to predict
there are ways to address it I'm not
talking about this today namely the the
the state preparation can be done
efficiently using um hadamar Gates and
at the end of the of the cman evolution
it turns out by applying a Quantum fua
transform which is also um an efficient
in the sense of being
a um it has a quadratic cost and require
circuits of quadratic depth in the
number of cubits um after doing this
Quantum fua transform it turns out that
measurement in the uh quantum computer
can be decoded into a measurement of the
classical observable that one is
interested in predicting um and this
scheme has this positivity preservation
property that we talked about earlier it
is asymptotically consistent as the
number of cubits increases and it has an
advantage in this very specific sense I
don't want to you know over definitely
not want to over claim here uh in the
sense that it can simulate um spaces of
observable which are exponentially large
using circuits that have uh quadratic
depth so the running time of the
algorithm is quadratic in the number of
cubits and that allows you to simulate
the evolution of observables in an
exponentially large uh dimensional k
space so um I'm just showing here one or
two examples where we have applied that
into into simple um uh you know um
systems like harmonic oscillators or
know quasi periodic uh systems that uh
live on a Taurus so to have a more
interesting this is evolution this is
comparing the the true Evolution with um
the the um ensemble mean that one
obtains from uh a collection of quantum
measurements done at the end or sorry
from an ensemble of uh Quantum
identically prepared Quantum systems uh
that uh this is done in a simulated you
know Quantum circuit experiment so you
can see that with um certain number of
cubits we can get uh we can get a
reasonable reconstruction of the true
Evolution and uh that's that would be
the last point we also had some actual
experiments done on a
IBM quantum computer using three cubits
so this is admittedly for a very simple
system just a harmonic harmonic
oscillator um where beyond that we found
that basically the noise in the quantum
computer uh prevented us from getting a
um any meaningful any meaningful results
but I think this is encouraging because
at least um we get a consistent you know
this is like a ideal Quantum circuit
versus the actual one um I'll bit for
this system a simple system we can get a
consistent uh uh reasonably consistent
uh correspondent okay so with that I
will stop and I'll just leave this here
and I um sorry for taking a little bit
longer well thank you so much that was a
wonderful talk um and let's have a Q&A
session although we had a question in
the middle um during the talk um is
there anyone who wants to ask questions
please unmute yourself and ask
and and for those of you who are in
person in that room physically please
please ask questions as well if you have
if you have one well I can start with
one um when you when you you know show
the the chart like showing the classical
uh the Dynamics and there's a mapping
from classical to Quantum and Quantum to
comput Quantum computational there
there's a map you have to Define right
mhm um and is that map has to be
linear in uh with respect to the input
space no no actually it's yeah that's
one of the few places where the mappings
are not linear like um if we look at um
uh sorry just go back real quick um if
you look at this map here this is this
cman wman embedding this is actually a
nonlinear M because it involves
basically you know we're doing
operations like square roots um and uh
so this is actually the these mappings
are one of the few places where this
scheme is is nonlinear I mean the other
plac is the measurement when we do the
quantum State um update um uh but yeah
in general these mappings here are are
not not not
linear yeah it's just f f fascinating
to me I mean me being not familiar with
this this subject um how how people
identify those nonl
map there must be some some
rules well I I don't know if I can say
something to intelligent maybe Elon will
have some comments on that but like if I
were to get a have a a shot is like uh
there are maybe some um at least some
guidelines like you want uh like for
instance you might say okay we want to
have our classical probability density
we're going to look for a um sort of so
called Vector State Vector state it
means that it's a it's a density
operator that you can characterize by a
specific wave function so it's like a
single function that characterizes like
a rank one projection operator so we
have to basically identify like a a
function that is a unit Vector U since
this is a projection operator from the
data that we were given namely that
probability density and uh well uh since
a probability density is a uh positive
function that integrates to one if I
want to turn it into a unit Vector on a
hilber space which is contains Square
integrable functions well maybe the
square root is not a bad no a bad idea
um and here's the formula yeah there's a
more principled way of thinking about
this yeah yeah I mean but I mean there's
also nonlinearity in a sense in the
choice of like um how you how you like
what coordinates say you would choose on
space or what right like how you know
like because H and X are very different
objects AMA like gives you an enormous
amount of freedom in how you make that
identification but like you know
and um you know maybe you want if the
Dynamics has obey some symmetry so you
want to like encode that with a proper
choice of coordinates on X then the
symmetries need to have a special
representation on H um you know having
to do with how that gamma map is acting
but in general I mean in general
um I think you know con construction of
these Maps is kind of like uh sort of
Cutting Edge research topic I think
Demetri and his his his you know
colleagues have have you know done
amazing work uh you know in terms of
pushing the envelope here got it got it
well from from the perspective of You
Know video model guy I'm I'm I'm one of
them and they this operator mapping
that's we do all the times um in the
context of um you know we generally the
reason we we are doing that operator
mapping because the original the
Dynamics is in really really high
dimensional space and um you want to
reduce that to lower dimensional space
and do that mapping like typically we
call it compression um there are linear
map and nonlinear map map and we do that
all the times to bring those High
dimensional space to the low dimensional
space and um as you guys mentions you
know if there's a some physical property
we would like to preserve uh we follow
that rule um those physical
property uh to guide us to come up with
those mapping like from high dimensional
to low dimensional um yeah so so there
is a some connection
between RAM and I mean one one definite
you know clear example is DMD DMD is a
one commum
operator and it does the linear
compression like the SVD type of mapping
from high dimensional to low dimensional
one thing I should not is that this
is this at least this map this is kind
of like the opposite of a compression is
like an extreme s of Dimension
augmentation yeah it's it's a lifting
yeah because you start from a space
which it's in some sense much smaller
than than this space we're creating a
copy of probability measures into
Quantum States yeah I mean what the
compression happens when we go from here
and then we go to this like you know
level of density matrices and that you
can that is a compression like um
there's a there's a concept called lift
and something and where there's a you
know the original govering equation is
very complex nonlinear um but you do the
argumentations basically lifting what
you just said and in order to transform
that complex nonlinear problems to the
quadar problems and then once you
convert that to quadratic it's easy to
um deal you know reduce further to low
dimensional space so there there's a um
the work
by um the German people and also Karen
wi in UTS team um are you familiar with
that uh yeah uh lift and learn yeah
exactly exactly exactly yeah yeah it's
it's it's in kind of a similar yeah I
think that's a common strategy like that
you going to bigger spaces gives you um
maybe more flexibility than to to to
design you know approximation schemes
that have some properties that you
couldn't easily get
otherwise and you guys that's what
you're doing right in basically um at
least in this in this example uh yeah
because here there's nothing specific to
Quantum Computing I mean this you could
just you know think of it purely as a
numerical um data driven scheme for you
know data simulation
it gives you this type of benefits again
I'm not arguing that there are no other
ways of course there are different ways
of enforcing positivity you know um uh
you know uh
approximations uh but but you know the
the thing I was trying to argue is that
certain operations that are non-trivial
in the function world like for instance
you know how do you make sure that you
preserve positivity of positive
functions um they become come somehow
almost automatic I would say in the
operator world because it's easy to
preserve positivity in this in this case
it's easy to preserve positivity of
operators yeah under projections yeah
interesting interesting there are other
similar I mean I didn't talk about this
at all today but like for instance if
you if you're in interested in
representing uh generators uh which are
um first order differential operators of
deterministic Dynamics like the uh that
the the one of the fundamental like
algebraic properties is that they
satisfy liit rule like if I take the
derivative of the product of two
functions we know how to do that you
know with the there's a product rule for
differentiation um and there is no
non-trivial uh operator that satisfies
that rule on finite dimensional
uh um
spaces commutative spaces so if I take a
a function space and I discretize it
somehow um I cannot satisfy the liess
rule uh but on the other hand it's very
easy to satisfy the liit rule with
matrices if you take you know for
instance if I have a matrix a and I take
the commutator between that Matrix and
any product of other Matrix I look at
the commutator of A and B time C then it
follows that you know this satisfies
basically a liess rule so it's um uh you
know there are certain operations that
certain structures that are easier to to
to represent in finite Dimensions using
spaces of operators than
functions cool cool very interesting
well is there any other questions Maybe
I can I make just a couple comments I
mean I think that there's two maybe
difference or two interesting
differences between what's happening
here and any other sort of dilation
technique which is that you know in
addition to like coming up with this
interesting
mapping um you're also working with the
quantum probability Theory and so you
you've like aug mented your
understanding of what the rules of
probability do um there's potentially
value in that and you know so the second
comment is specifically if you were
modeling the evolution of an actual
Quantum system you would need to use
those types of of probability with like
the what you spoke about as as like the
quantum base rule that's that's
essential for actually doing datadriven
modeling of quantum
systems and um there's like an enormous
effort you know in trying to do that
across the country at you know almost
every University but I mean right now we
have Stephanie you know sitting in the
room right she she's working on ideas
like that for modeling you know actual
Quantum Hardware that people are
building on that and so it's you're
augmenting your ability to do these data
driven systems you know not just in the
representation but in your notion of
probability which means the difference
being you can form what what are called
the superposition states where you can
be in a combination of zero and one um
like Demitrius didn't talk much about
what how cubits differ from classical
bits but you know they they can have a
probability anywhere between zero and
one in fact they're like it represent
the two-dimensional manifold that's the
surface of the sphere so like you could
never be able to work with that uh
object naturally if you applied you know
the standard rules of
cability that almost all of these
Frameworks are built on any kind of AAS
and framework and here you're actually
augmenting your ability to deal with
these quantum systems
naturally um so there's some physical
systems for which this will most
certainly be a much more natural
representation I mean that that should
be like an an important I know it's very
abstract but but like there like almost
all fundamental systems obey quantum
mechanics and so that means there should
be some evolution in the way we think
about
quility yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think that's a very good
point and and uh maybe related to that
we haven't studied this at all but like
what might be interesting to think about
is that once you go to this uh you know
finite dimensional again representation
but then you're using Quantum versions
of you know probability and up you know
Basi and update um is there anything to
be said about having more cap capacity
to encode information or make more um
yeah a better representation of your
underlying you know unknown classical
state with for the same number of uh for
the same you know Dimension uh basically
uh you know just basically just because
you're accessing all these uh um you're
accessing potentially more States Quant
you know uh in your statistical
representation of the know um you know
hidden state of your dynamical system
maybe there are some
benefits there I don't know well I mean
you showed one at the very end like
where you you know basically you could
interpret the theorem that he talked
about at the end is saying there's an
exponentially efficient representation
for any integrable dynamical
system and what you you're able to do
then is to dynamically evolve an
exponentially large number of states
essentially for the cost of you know you
know a single or you know
logarithmically smaller amount of
information um because you basically
encode this in the set of
cubits um so it's I mean it it's you
don't get something for nothing um but
but you do get an a certain type of
quantum advantage that is potentially
very
valuable um I mean doing this for for
chaotic Dynamics which is more generic
it's not as easy no but but like you
know again that's sort of Cutting Edge
like how how would you how would you do
that
um anyway I hope so it's like some of
these operations are actually if you had
a quantum computer you could do them
much more
efficient if that makes
sense
like exponentially more efficient
depending on what kinds of questions
we're trying to
ask is Stephanie still
there am oh good well I mean I mean I
don't
know I'm guessing you are very inspired
by Dimitri's talk maybe you can combine
you know the
um um neural neur neural OD idea you're
you're applying maybe you can um apply
that after some mapping um and then to
the neural
operator neural OD thingy um theod of
you know the the
combination what do you think Stephanie
I at this point it's a little over my
head have to
admit but I'm curious it say
really the first time I see a talk like
this um I think I'll have to adjust so
maybe
yes yeah maybe additional meeting with
stepan would help sounds good oh all
right well I'm in there was
one uh for example in first one is you
have a scaling for and square uh in your
B implementation does it but you have
actually time Evolution does it this n
Square includes time Evolution H it's a
good point so this circuit uh it's for
one at the moment at least the way we
have set it up it's for one this is
giving you the evolution at at the end
of this for one fixed fixed time so that
one time for for or bit it can it can be
as as long as you want it to be because
it's integrable system you can fast
forward it so you can oh okay so
sublinear time scale exactly exactly
because you know how to yeah usually
this is an interesting question like
what's the complexity of the evolution
operation here and and it's a very
interesting question from the point of
view of quantum algorithms you know can
you attain linear scaling in the time
steps or some algorithms have to do
quadratic number of time step like
quadratic work with number of time steps
which is weird compared to you know
classical systems but here because it's
integrable you can essentially you know
fast forward the video tape all the way
to the final time step and immediately
print the result at least fast
forwarding is specific for Quantum
specific for inable systems for for yeah
yeah that have this pure Point Spectrum
Property yeah actually V Square it LO
measurements so you perform fre
transformation just me B stre yeah and
the reason that we do that is uh
because
uh one of the issues with Quantum
Computing is that you're not you cannot
measure any Quantum observable at the
end you have to measure you're stuck
with measuring a specific one associated
with a Quantum computational basis so
the cubits so you want to rotate the
state such that uh in that in that so
when you do make that measurement it
actually gives you um uh a
correspondence with the underlying
classical thing that you're trying to
predict and it turns out the the quantum
fua transform for for the kind for the
class of these multiplication operators
that we use to represent um our
classical observables approximately
diagonalizes them so that means that you
can uh by doing the quantum F transform
you rotate your state in a way that uh
uh a Quant measurement can be encoded or
decoded rather into a nan value or a
measurement of the multiplication
operator that we care about so you kind
of measure index in a spectrum and after
conver yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah and
the last question is about this
forecasting data simulation of
measurement
cyle maybe you can go to the
slide
yeah uh so basically understand you need
to perform this forecast and and
Analysis for some J some J for some yeah
J is the number of sorry I was going too
fast here the number of time steps
between observations but after if you
perform if you like to analyze another
time step you you need to repeat
everything um okay so that's that's
another good point so here this is you
can think of it as an inference
procedure
similarly to like basian like sequential
basian inference In classical statistics
here we're not doing any physical you
know Quantum Quantum measure yeah that
that's a great point that you know one
of the challenges I think with
implementing an algorithm like this
which is sequential in nature is like
and and you are actually doing real
Quantum measurements that because those
would destroy your State uh afterwards
it just was I was curious that maybe you
kind of by doing measurements you
collapse your state after that you
propagate collapse St orinal state
but now you just collapse measure and
repeat uh yeah we well right now we're
not doing any physical physical um uh
measurement so in other words we don't
have to explicitly like repe you know
prepare you know the state we can simply
apply this rule to obtain a new density
operator okay I mean I think uh
extending it to the fully Quantum case
would be really
interesting yeah and maybe there are
something to be said here there could be
some role for Quantum sensors like in
the sense of
uh yeah like uh to to be able to couple
the the the quantum state with the
whatever we get from from the underlying
system whatever we observe from the
underlying system without destroying it
but I don't know if
that's I mean I yeah it depends on on
the level of description but
you you could certainly destroy it or I
mean you don't necessarily destroy it
you just project it
yeah oh but but but then maybe the other
issue is like when we do actually want
to make a
forecast like meaning to get a number
out of it right then then we do have
to uh destroy it in some sense project
it uh uh
state if you project to something you
cannot continue your
time I mean it'll have a different it
different
Evolution it may have even the same
hamiltonian just a different starting
from you
know I mean I think people I would love
to see people working this out I think
it would be it's pretty
Val for dealing with the F information
directly I mean I mean
that the same moment before the
measurement you have some positional
States but together describe time
Evolution but if you collapse it you
will have just one time step and
basically you you lose quantums
without you might lose well I mean maybe
you just projected an anilla now
you're okay I think I think that I think
that's the final comment from the peut
gallery over
here I don't know I was not monitoring
the chat or anything like that couldn't
see I hope there was no no there is no
question from the chat yeah um unless
there is other questions from the
audience you you can jump in um I see
Lee here and
also ban
here you guys are welcome to jump in um
otherwise from the perspective of you
know formal ddpr seminar maybe we can uh
just end it and stop the record button
and um just continue the discussions
well let's in that um Spirit let's thank
our speaker Dimitrius for wonderful talk
and nice nice Q&A sessions thank you so
much thank you thank for
coming